Tony who's gonna be playing the game of
football the future NFL player there's a
crisis right now when it comes to head
injuries and will there be less college
football players less of a pool for the
NFL teams to draft from yeah I
definitely think so and that's something
that you know obviously you know for me
and as long as I played 17 years of
National Football League and the life
lessons I learned you know as a kid and
you know playing in high school I think
that's gonna be out the door because I
think now with movies coming out and all
the studies coming out and as a parent
you got to say you know should I let my
child play and win should I let him play
I know there's things that are saying
that you shouldn't let your kid play
till he's 18 well the only kid plays to
18 I mean what's like what's the college
system don't look like obviously it's
gonna affect the NFL game so it's I
think the pool is still gonna be there
because there always gonna be kids that
say you know what I want to be the next
tony gonzalez I'm gonna be the next
Peyton Manning so I think the pool is
still gonna be there I just think the
level of the talent level might drop a
little bit